yeah dude you know the first time I saw
you I went to school at University of
California at Santa Barbara I grew up
here in New York but I went to school at
UCSB and I managed a restaurant called
bricks Cafe and once a week there was a
comedy night yes do you remember I
didn't know that you managed a joint
though there was a comedy in in in in a
I think it was like a small crate yeah
in the
corner let me see if I got the right the
right restaurant you walk in this is and
wasn't it to the left and there's a full
window so people can see from the
outside you you managed that place I had
no
idea right into two restaurants into
managed two restaurants both out of
business did you start did you start the
comedy night no it was Andre belloff he
wasn't even a
comic he weren I was yeah literally I
was just a you know I was just a fan of
Comedy like I I watched it growing up
and it was just random that I was
working at this restaurant and then this
guy opened another one and he was dumb
enough to like let me manage it like I
wrote him a manual I was like this is
what I think you should do and like gave
it to him and he was this Argentine guy
and he was like I think this guy's good
I think no wasn't good but I remember
you coming there there's a bunch of
people that came up I think TIG came up
I think uh Brett erns you came up I
remember you doing the Ross bit oh my
god dude and which is like iconic bit
it's hard to do the Ross bit in there
say again it's hard to do the hard to
you almost fell off the St no
room sure didn't far sh like 20 ft but
it was like I remember watching it and I
and you know you're not like a talent
scout at the time but but I'm just like
holy like this is something
different the energy is something
different going on here and then um and
then you really exploded huh
that from that restaurant
career what was I was trying to think
this like real quick my first story also
it was 2007 I just started
comedy in LA and we go watch there's a
every like the three major clubs had
their Black Knight comedy stores was
tripping on Tuesday which wasn't the
roughest room but it's like it can be
choppy Sebastian goes on stage I'm
watching this white dude goes it's dead
he lets the silence sit for like 10 15
seconds this white dude all black room
and then he just then one girl Woos and
he just goes no I like that confidence
and then the confidence he had I swear
to you I don't think to this day I've
ever seen a comic level of room like
that I think you're talking about Kramer
at the laugh
at no dude Tony Roberts who's so funny
and such a killer host he gets back on
stage for three minutes he's laughing at
Sebastian's bit like about uh some like
the the the drinks with the umbrella in
it he's dying laughing leaning over the
stool like the dude I was sitting with
got an umbrella in his drink I never
seen and that was the first time I ever
was like oh that's what you can do with
a set I'd been watching comedy but that
stuck with me for years okay I I need to
I need to get back to like the beginning
do you start in LA or did you start in
Chicago I started in Los Angeles I moved
in 1998 from Chicago I graduated
Northern Illinois University I did
comedy once there for the upand
cominging or or no it was up it was the
uh the guy coming in to to entertain the
students whatever it was a headliner
College entertainment yeah you opened
for I opened up for that guy and then
that's the only time I had the frat
brothers come out who the you were in a
frat weren't you yeah yeah at that time
my parents came no no no
which they were worried because I died I
died on stage that night and they were
like this is what we're paying college
for
a so uh I moved out in 98 and I just
started kicking around Los Angeles doing
like Open Mic nights and and so you
bombed and was like no this is what I'm
going to do I just knew I felt
comfortable up there and this was where
I should be I was a huge fan of standup
at a young age and I always knew I was
going to go into standup comedy I just
didn't know how who who was your guy who
was your introduction uh I used to watch
HBO um at night at The Improv all that
stuff at my cousin's house on Saturday
morning because I never I didn't have
cable so I used to watch all of that
stuff and I used to digest it like it
was Game
tape fascinated like Jesus how did they
remember all this this is fantastic I
want to do this how do you even get into
this you my dad's a beautician my my
mother's a a secret ter like where do
you even go to do this but I just fell
in love with it and then uh decided I
was going to move out to Los Angeles in
1998 to pursue a a care was there one
standup that you saw that you're like
holy like I remember seeing Bernie Mack
when I was younger yeah and it didn't
make me go I want to be a standup
comedian but it made me go holy
that's how hard you can make people
laugh like that was the bar and
obviously like Eddie delirious but like
was there someone you saw it wasn't like
a guy that came out what I used to do is
watch Johnny Carson at night and then H
used to have comedians on and I was like
oh wow this is great and people come in
and make people laugh and then I started
getting into it from there I started W
watching George Carlin and Eddie Murphy
uh Don Rickles I was a huge fan of Don
Rickles so it was a variety of different
comedians that I saw over you know a
period of time it wasn't one guy where I
where I go oh yeah that's that's the guy
was it was a culmination of people okay
you're just obsessed with the sport of
Comedy okay so you go out to LA when I
remember you doing the Vince vaugh yeah
what was it called the wild wild west
comedy show is that the first break is
that the first time where you feel like
I have some traction or were you already
like the
local guy I was not anything I was just
going doing comedy clubs not touring at
all I was working at the for job yeah it
was I I Oh I thought this I thought at
this point You' already kind of like you
were like established la like headlining
locally no but no D so you had I'm I'm
still delivering chicken
sat to table 109 at the okay okay okay
when when Vince Von asked me to do this
I I I even find you at Dublin's uh there
was a place called Dublin's on Sunset
that's it had a uh like a comedy night
comedy night Tuesday night Dublin and it
was upstairs Timberlake used to go Vince
vau it was like a
for celebrities at the point you know
Dane Cook at that time was the guy and I
met him there through a comedian by the
name of Amed Amed yeah yeah and uh and
Vince and I started talking in this
stairwell he's from Chicago I'm from
Chicago starts talking this that and the
other next thing you know a couple
months go by and through Amed asked me
to come on the Vince V wild west comedy
show so I had to go ask work can I take
a month off to be in a
movie cuz I didn't know I mean I wasn't
getting paid a lot of money it wasn't
like something I could just lose my job
and I'm very responsible you know what
you're doing you're signing up at prize
picks use a promo code Schultz and they
will match your initial deposit up to
$100 that means you put in a 100 you get
100 for free that's all you got to do
price.com promo code Schultz let's get
back to the show I feel very responsible
like um the first thing my mother asked
me when I moved out in 1998 what are you
going to do for health
insurance I'm not one of these guys that
just lives on people's
couches set up I came out with
savings you know not like Axel Rose
where he's got a Qatar and some change I
came out with 10 grand responsible
signed a
lease and uh so um yeah I took off work
for a month but I never went back after
that that was 2005 so 98 to like a
subplot in the movie I remember about
you waiting tables right yeah all right
guys show dates you know what it is
first of all this Friday December 8th my
first show ever in nin I love New
Orleans I went there one time it was
honestly it's the most unique city in
America I am so excited to go there I
love it also December 17th 18th 19th you
know what it is UK Glasgow glasgo I
think uh London we added a second show
there's still some tickets left in
Manchester that show is going to sell
out soon if it hasn't already get your
tickets for that also January 6th 8th
and 9th I'm going to Oslo Amsterdam we
added a second show in einhoven and
January 18th through I'm going to be in
Washington DC at The Improv those
tickets will sell out too and January
26th and 27th Wise Guys Comedy Club in
Salt Lake City I've never been to your
Mormon ass state I'm very excited to
come I've heard the club is amazing so
get your tickets for all those shows and
more being added soon at Akash singh.com
now let's get back to this show okay
that night that Vince is there did you
know that he's watching when you're
going on or did you already go on and
then you saw him in the hallway I didn't
know he was in the room so I had gone on
and came off so much better
he was delivering the chicken sat T to
him I had waited on Vince Swan though
years before that yeah but he didn't
know that I mean I I waited on him I
think in 2001 but uh tip good does he
tip good he didn't pay it was agents
that so I pretty know pretty much know
of every celebrity tipping habits
working at the Four Seasons so and and
what do we got Shaq's the best wow what
is Shaq do what is sha Shaq come in on a
Sunday by himself walk through the bar
sit used to sit by himself this is not
every Sunday but you know a few yeah
order a uh um a fruit plate yeah you
just protected Shaq right there what you
every Sunday not everyone
maybe maybe a couple times Shaq was
there a few times a few times right
after
church and then uh little fruit plate
little uh little um what else did he
have oh he or coffee but I used to serve
the coffee to him in a big campet Ino
cup because it's like serving a giant
you know
like I could serve him a little teacup
bring out the The Big C but and he would
uh never asked for a check just left
$100 under the plate every time every
time and uh at that point you know I
wasn't that like hey what's up Shaq I
was you know very professional you had
to act like you know that wasn't a
celebrity hello Mr O'Neal how you doing
and uh yeah he was one of the best
tippers there